I'm joined now by Connor Darcy from the
resolution foundation so Connor just to
be clear you're talking about people who
work for platforms like uber and
delivery not necessarily all
self-employed people so if you call up a
plumber say and you look them up online
and they work for themselves they
obviously you know they can't pay
themselves the minimum wage it doesn't
really mean anything but if they were
working for say a plumbing company and
the plumbing company tells them you have
to charge this amount for this type of
work though they don't have control over
the price they set so we're saying that
for firms in that position who use
self-employed labor they should be
guaranteeing that you know the people
that they're giving this work to are
getting at least the minimum wage isn't
the danger of this that it's going to
put an awful lot more of a workload on
HMRC because they're gonna have to
administer this and make sure that these
companies are paying the minimum wage I
think you know you wouldn't want it to
be checked in absolutely every instance
and you wouldn't need to expand the
funding for HMRC but I think the
important thing in this is to make sure
that the firms are are you know
accepting this duty that they would have
to go and do this test to make sure that
the rates that they're paying for the
type of work that they're offering would
actually give the minimum wage to
someone and then if you know for those
cases where it doesn't look like it's
being paid and that's where HMRC can get
involved can investigate and remind us
what the status is of uber drivers right
now there's a case going through the
course at the moment I mean are they
classed that's currently a self-employed
still yes so this is where it gets
really important but also quite complex
so you've got Buber drivers and in the
latest case they had they were found to
be workers and workers are a type of
self-employed person but they are
entitled to the minimum wage so
obviously you know that'll play out
firms can change the working
relationship to move them closer to
self-employment but we're saying that
you know obviously the gig economy gets
a lot of attention but there's lots of
other kinds of self-employed workers who
are truly independently self-employed
but take some work from companies you
know I mentioned plumbers but there's
also instance it's like hairdressers
where they're renting a chair as they
call it in a salon with less control so
we're saying that you know there's these
really important tribunals that are
going through they're crucial and
getting better enforcement's vital but
also you know giving a basic kind of
floor for the wages of a lot of people
would make a big difference isn't the
problem though that the essence of
self-employed work it's essentially
about doing a job rather than
necessarily the hours that you pay to do
it and if you push up the price of doing
the job by hiking up
early rate some people aren't going to
want to take on those services anymore
you know this is the argument that we
had with the minimum wage initially that
people worry that if you give it to
employees then you'd risk you know
either damaging their employment risk or
you know you make food and basic kind of
goods more expensive what we found is
that there's been some kind of pass
through from the minimum wage to prices
but there hasn't been an effect on
employment and hasn't really massively
changed things and they approach that
we're taking is you know saying not just
paying self-employed people by the hour
but when they're doing the task so when
they're there our couriers when they're
on a delivery if they're an uber driver
when they're driving making sure that
they have that and these minimum
guarantee so you're gonna call for these
kind of people to take that holiday pay
as well and sick pay things like that
but I think in the you know there's a
bigger argument to be had around how we
treat the self-employed and I think
there's definitely some more there are
rights than we could send to them like
statutory maternity pay which which they
don't get at the moment and there's a
you know the tailor review is gonna take
a broader look at this but I think for
the moment we're just focusing on the
minimum wage but one of the most
important things we could do and that
the government's looked at before is
starting to equalize the tax treatment
because at the moment there's a big
incentive for both the separated person
and the firm to to say they're
self-employed whether or not that's true
so trying to even up the playing field
on that would help to get rid of some of
this bogus effort all right so that was
Philip Hammonds attempt to equalize
national insurance rates for the
self-employed and the employed say so
you're in favor of that absolutely again
because it it's not the lowest earning
self-employed people that get affected
by that it's it's a lot of the growth in
South employment recently has been in
higher paid sectors so potentially as I
said if there's a you know a basic
fairness point in the tax system but
then there's also what are we you know
how do we get money in at this point
when everyone's talking about austerity
and finding a bit of money to spend
elsewhere
I mean some would say why not just hit
the companies themselves harder why not
impose greater legislation on them so I
think you know there's obviously there's
the employee or self-employed Nick's
there's class 2 and class 4 and class 1
but there's also this employer Nick's
which is the big difference because
firms who are using self-employed labor
don't have to pay this nearly 14 percent
tax so trying to you know maybe bring
that in is something that we start to
move in that direction but for a
government to do that obviously it's
quite politically brave so we'll have to
see if something happens on
all right Connor Darcy from the
resolution foundation appreciate you
joining me complicated issue explained
it well in English thanks